I
guess there's no one to moderate this session, so I'm Juanita Merchant.
So
we will
go ahead and get started.
So I'll be talking about granulocyte reprogramming in
gastric metaplasia,
and then the tumor microenvironment.
So basically, I think most people in the audience will understand
that gastric adenocarcinoma, most of it is initiated
by the infection by Helicobacter pylori, and
so this cancer should be
treatable. No one should really have to die from this.
Again, just hitting on a couple of the highlights.
It's the fifth most
common cancer worldwide, 11,000 deaths.
The classic risk factor, 70% to 90% of gastric
cancers are due to Helicobacter pylori, but don't forget about Epstein-Barr
virus. And I'll show a little bit of information from our
mouse model where
nitrates, I think, will be important perhaps in
accelerating or increasing the incidence of
the metaplasia in cancer.
Also, high salt has been associated.
In the US, the prevalence has declined but is rising
in minority populations. And living in Arizona, where we
have a high Hispanic and Native
American population, there's a fourfold higher incidence
of gastric cancer, usually due to
Helicobacter pylori in those communities.
And then it's known that worldwide, most of the gastric cancer
tends to be in Asia.
So what I'd like to cover today is our
rationale for looking at this particular
subset of
immune cells,
granulocytic myeloid-derived suppressor cells, that seem
to
require hedgehog and type I interferon signaling to initiate
this reprogramming. And I'll show you the evidence that we
developed from our mouse models,
based upon the Correa paradigm. And then
show some evidence of why we can
use an inhibitor of cyclic GMP
phosphodiesterases to actually possibly shrink the tumors,
first in mice, and then we use that information to set
up a clinical trial to test this in
humans. So,
well-known to the group is that these myeloid-derived
suppressor cells are a heterogeneous collection of
immune-suppressive cells that can arise from the monocytic
or granulocytic, i.e., neutrophil lineage.
They're
a suppressive myeloid cell, and
due to their ability to suppress the effector
using CD8 positive T cells.
And the major thought is that this is due to their ability to
consume a very important amino acid that's important
in the proliferation of T cells, L-arginine.
So this is an initial schematic
of what we think may be going on, and I'll show you the
evidence for this in the subsequent slides, is that
during a Helicobacter infection, initially, you're going to have the
neutrophils there in the acute phase.
And they normally will make reactive oxygen species,
and
T cells can proliferate normally.
However, we found that in the presence of
type I interferons, which I'll show you, and we have some
earlier data, that the evidence is probably coming
from the activation of plasmacytoid dendritic
cells from damp signals in the debris field in the
chronic inflammation. But that type I interferons
can initiate the polarization
of these
granulocyte, basically neutrophils,
to become immunosuppressive. And what I'm showing you here is
a sort of complicated diagram. What we found is that
type I interferons can upregulate both arginase
and nitric oxide synthase, which, of course,
will consume L-arginine to
generate nitric oxide.
Nitric oxide is a cofactor for soluble
guanylate cyclase. It consumes
GTP
to generate cyclic GMP.
Cyclic GMP does not continue to accumulate
because
also upregulated in the presence of type I interferons in these
cells are the cyclic GMP-dependent
phosphodiesterases.
And so cyclic GMP is a cofactor for these
phosphodiesterases, which then break down
cyclic GMP to regenerate the substrate for GTP.
So this cycle can keep going, and if this
cell is upregulating these reactive oxygen
species,
then this cell does not undergo
apoptosis because
it also upregulates these phosphodiesterases and keeps the
level of cyclic GMP low.
Okay. I'll come back to that slide.
I know that's a complicated biochemical concept, but we'll
come back to it again.What I'm showing you here
is what we call the Correa paradigm that was published by
Pelayo Correa in "Lancet" in 1975.
So before the discovery of Helicobacter pylori, they showed
that chronic inflammation in patients that eventually developed
gastric cancer went through this intermediate step
of developing
these metaplasias, which are basically a mucus cell phenotype,
but also in the setting of the loss of the normal acid-secreting cell
population, the parietal cells, and then eventually the
pepsinogen-producing chief cells.
So back in 2000, there was a report from Andy
McMahon's lab, who was at that point in time at
Harvard,
that
reported that the sonic hedgehog knockout mouse developed
gastric metaplasia. So we said, "Oh, that's interesting.
Well, maybe the hedgehog signaling pathway is important in this
transition from chronic gastritis to the loss of
the acid-secreting cells and the development of metaplasia."
So we raised that question, and this is important
because I'm a gastroenterologist, and so when I scope a lot of these
patients, they many times don't have Helicobacter pylori
around once they've developed metaplasia, and certainly in the
setting of gastric cancer. So we do need to understand
and possibly target this inflammatory process, which
we think is the major driver, plus or minus some other
maybe change in the gastric microbiome or other agents
such as nitrates, which would come from the diet.
This is actually a picture of what the intestinal type and colonic type
of metaplasia looks like in the stomach.
So it's this colonic type that is thought to be more closely
associated with gastric cancer.
So the first question we ask in the mouse model was,
"Okay, if hedgehog is involved, what
are the cells that are actually expressing the
readout for hedgehog signaling?" And so we were able to
acquire the Glee1 LacZ mice from
Alex Joyner in New York. And
the Glee1 transcription
factor
is a readout and is upregulated in the presence of
hedgehog, and is stained here in green.
So these are myofibroblasts. So in the resting state, in the absence
of Helicobacter infection, the myofibroblasts are
the primary
recipients of the hedgehog signaling pathway.
However,
after a two-month infection with Helicobacter species,
so in the mice, you get a much more robust inflammatory response
with Helicobacter felis, and there's the infiltration of these other
Glee1 positive cells, which when you do flow cytometry,
you'll find that they are
myeloid cells. So we also use the Glee1
deletion mouse. So actually, the LacZ reporter is
knocked into the Glee1 locus so you can maintain these mice in a
homozygous Glee1 null state. They're perfectly viable.
Infect them with Helicobacter. And here, what we
found, again in the mouse, is this metaplastic change
occurs in the wild-type infected mice at six months.
However, in mice that either maintain
a-- or in the heterozygous state for Glee1 or
homozygous Glee1 knockout or LacZ-LacZ, since it's knocked
into the Glee1 locus, you'll notice that the
architecture of the stomach is completely normal.
So,
as I mentioned, the Glee1
expressing cell population during the Helicobacter infection is
actually an immune cell. So this is basically saying that if you
disrupt something in the immune
microenvironment, that you can maintain the normal architecture of
the stomach epithelium.
So this is a summary, and this is already
published.
The flow cytometry analysis showing that most of the cells
that were Glee1 positive were of the myeloid lineage, and we'll come
back to that.
So since Glee1 is a transcription factor, that
allows us to look at what the downstream targets.
At the time in 2015, '16,
so 10 years ago when we initially started this study, we were using
microarrays and found that in the mice
that-- the wild-type mice, you can see an upregulation
of certain genes, including something called
Slitph1. But in the Glee1 null mice or
LacZ-LacZ mice, that there was a
significant decrease in these genes.
And so we went on to do chromatin
immunoprecipitation, to show that
this Slitph1, which in the literature at the time had
been shown to be important in myeloid cell differentiation, which
is the reason why of the different genes that we had
studied in or identified in this microarray that we focused
on Slitph1. There is also a paralog
Slitph2 which has been studied, but the reason why we went with
Slitph1 is because the Slitph2 does not exist in
the human genome. So we stuck with four, and I'll
come back to later when we talk about the human studies, the
ortholog of
Slitph1.So that allowed
us to
start to mark these cells or think about marking these cells
by following this Slitph1-4 signature.
So we developed, and again, this is already published,
a Slitph1-4 tdTomato
Cre-ERT2 mouse that was then
activated in
the... Well, we actually did a bone marrow transplant
so that all the immune cells could be marked by this
tdTomato signature.
The wild-type mice at four months do not show any
metaplastic changes, and you don't see any of these
tdTomato-positive cells. So these mice are infected.
If I showed you the H&E, there's plenty of inflammation there.
However, in a mouse where we
bred the mice onto a mice that's
overexpressing the Hedgehog ligand,
you can see here that there are these tdTomato-positive
cells. High power view is shown here.
You're able to
sort for those cells. You can see they have a granulocytic nucleus.
They also express markers of MDSCs.
In addition, since we could sort them out, we could actually perform T-cell
suppressor assays. So based upon the markers, their
upregulation of arginase and nitric oxide synthase,
we designated that the Slitph1-4-positive
cells, which we could follow with this tdTomato signature,
were
myeloid-derived suppressor cells.
We, at the time, wanted to go back and actually ask the question, why was
Hedgehog required for these cells to be
expressed? Because remember, in the knockout, we actually
see a normal architecture of the stomach.
And so we were able to
sort the cells out
from wild-type mice and place them in
culture. And so these are cells from the stomach, and here we're
following the Slitph1-4 message.
And then if you incubate those cells with recombinant Sonic Hedgehog, we get a
little bit of stimulation. With H.
felis alone in blue. But the two together synergize,
and the strongest inducer of
Slitph1-4, which was known in the literature, is a type I
interferon. We also looked at beta, but alpha tended to be much stronger.
However, if you isolate the cells from those Glee1 laxI
laxI mice, which were essentially Glee1 null, you do not see the
induction of Slitph1. So underscoring the fact that
you actually need both the Hedgehog signal and the
type I interferon like the two keys to
unlock this promoter. So that meant that at least when we see those
cells, we know that those two signals are present in the tissue.
And indeed, if you look at the promoter, there is a
Glee1 binding site in the Slitph1 promoter, and then in the more
proximal promoter of Slitph1-4, there is the
downstream transcription factors that are
activated by interferon alpha or type I interferons.
So that begged the question, okay, what was the source of type I
interferons that may be activating these cells?
And it's known, and we were able to show that plasmacytoid dendritic
cells on a per cell basis is the most likely
source for the type I interferons.
So putting all of that together and published in
2022, what we're proposing is
that when Helicobacter infects the epithelium chronically,
there is going to be cell atrophy, maybe some cell debris,
and that debris becomes these
damage-activated molecular patterns, which can activate
plasmacytoid dendritic cells, usually through
TLR9. There's a certain pathway that will result in
the production of interferon alpha and the
polarization of the granulocytic or neutrophil population
that is already there that had been recruited to the stomach
to polarize to an immunosuppressive phenotype.
And indeed, in this study, we were able to show that if you infuse the mice with
interferon alpha antibodies, that you can block this
polarization and
still see the metaplasia.
So
we wanted to then analyze these cells in more detail,
and one of the first questions we asked was whether Slitph1-4
was essential for the
survival of these granulocytic MDSCs.
And so again, we could take advantage of the mouse models that we had already
created. So the tdTomato mouse, which I showed you the in vivo
expression of these Slitph1-positive cells, but we
could isolate them from the stomach or the bone marrow or spleen,
culture them, and then treat them with type I
interferon. You can see they're more numerous, and the flow cytometry
is shown here. So in the absence
of type I interferon and in presence, there's an induction
of this promoter and turns
on the tdTomato signal, so we can follow
these cells. The green is caspase, and then
in the presence of if we knock down
Slitph1-4, so knock down the actual message, these
cells in the presence of type I interferon will
increase their caspase signal here
with the flow cytometry. We're measuring it by annexin.
So we see an increase in apoptosis in these cells if you
knock down Slitph1-4. And if we do a T-cell
suppressor assay,
that there is less T-cell suppression.We then went
to the in vivo state and generated a
Glee1-CreERT2,
slafen floxed locus. And shown
here,
you can see there's plenty of inflammation
in the H. helicobacter-infected
mouse. This is the metaplastic change.
We call it SPIM in the mice.
However, there's less SPIM if we
knock out genetically slafen
4, and this is the immunofluorescence
staining for the metaplastic change.
And that's quantified here.
We also looked at, isolated those cells, and
performed the T cell assays to show that
in the presence of slafen 4, that
there is T cell suppression. However, knocking out
these cells if they're in culture, that you
are able to recover
the T cell suppressor
function.
So
if you knock out slafen 4,
you're disrupting, we think, triggering these cells to undergo
apoptosis that happen to be granulocytic MDSCs,
and you mitigate the metaplastic change.
So can we do this in vitro from
naive bone marrow-derived neutrophils?
Now I'm switching to some single-cell sequencing.
This work was published in 2023.
So in the infected mouse, you can see that there
is a cluster of cells that are positive for
slafen 4. Some of the characteristic
genes are shown here. And
then the violin plot is showing here
that this blue group
has more of the... Let's see. The blue is,
sorry, is three. So
group three, which is not labeled correctly here.
But basically, they are more the neutrophil group.
And then as slafen 4 signal
increases,
that you see a increase in
the... So I think two is here. So you see more of the
TNF, nitric oxide, IL1 alpha,
IL27, and then the highest level of slafen
expressing cells
is shown here with... It seems to have more arginase, et
cetera. And then we even did a pseudo time analysis suggesting that there
is a relationship
going from cells that are
expressing a low level of slafen to an intermediate,
which would be this group, to a higher level with the...
It seems to express more of the arginase 1.
So this suggests that,
and this is in vivo,
that there is reprogramming from a neutrophil
cell population that's already recruited there.
But then we actually
isolated granulocytes from the bone marrow, used
the Ficoll gradient, and then cultured these cells
for 24 hours and treated them with interferon
alpha. And you can see here that
about almost 30% of those cells will be CD11b
granulocyte
GR1 positive. And then this population,
if I ask the question, what percentage of
those cells are slafen positive, we can use our
tdTomato signal that gets turned on.
And of this population, about 85% of them are
slafen positive. So this slafen 4
signal is a subset
of the CD11b GR1 positive cells.
So using the single-cell sequencing to track
the granulocytic MDSCs in the human stomach,
obviously, to study this in people,
this can take decades.
And the question that we wanted to know is whether we
could use the ortholog of slafen 4, having
established this sort of trajectory
and mechanisms in the mouse model, could we study this
in humans? However,
the loci are pretty complicated. It is
slafen 12L, actually, that is the closest
ortholog to 4 in humans. So in the human
stomach, we'll be following the slafen
12L. There is a slafen 12. It's a
fairly complicated locus, so that is what we see.
Some
of these are my patients that we're following that already have
intestinal metaplasia, and we have to survey these patients because they're
at higher risk for progressing to gastric cancer.
But this is sort of the problem is that once you have
panintestinal metaplasia, we don't know who's going to progress
on to gastric cancer. So we
first wanted to see whether we could identify the
slafen 12L granulocytic MDSCs.
So at baseline, so this is four patients that basically come
for dyspepsia.
You don't see this-MDSC signal, which are
this sort of blue and purple. It's more the monocytic
lineage that's the blue, but the granulocytic MDSC
lineage is this pink. You can see that this
population, not present in normals, is present in the
metaplasia but becomes much more intense,
and more of these cells accrue within the gastric
cancer, but not in the adjacent
normal tissue to the cancer. So in other
words, if you biopsy... So these are actual, just
regular upper end
EGD biopsies.
So we can actually see that we're not biopsying close to the tumor,
that those cells are not present. So these cells are tracking within the
tumor, and obviously, since this is single-cell
sequencing, we can show that the
CD15-12L, which is the
granulocytic myeloid population, is
predominantly present in this population, and
that's quantified here, where you can see a step-up
from normal intestinal metaplasia to
within the tumor. This is the adjacent normal.
I'll come back to the T cells, but essentially, you're seeing a
decrease, and you can see that this is
going from 1,000 down to less than 100, that there
is a significant drop in the T cell and NK cell
population, which I will subtype a little bit later.
So,
can we inhibit the
SLUFN4 MDSC signal based upon
some of the genes that are being expressed in these cells?
And what I'm showing you here is a bulk RNA-seq that we
published in the 2023 paper
for the cells that were isolated by
bulk RNA-seq
using the tdTomato signal. So this is not a single-cell sequencing, but
we sort out the tdTomato-positive cells, and so you can
see some of the genes,
most of which are very strongly induced by type one interferons,
consistent with what our hypothesis was, including
an upregulation of
phosphodiesterase 6.
In addition, we did a pull-down to show that the
SLUFN-positive
protein will interact with these guanylate binding
proteins, which are important in generating GTP.
I include this gray
set of genes, which is actually from a paper
by
Mikael Pittet.
Zelonius is the first author. And they had set
up a
mouse lung tumor model showing that very
similar genes, which are shown in red, and also identifying
SLUFN4 in what they were calling the mouse
neutrophil 2 population.
So SLUFN4 appears to bind guanylate binding
proteins, which is based upon
this pull-down.
And so,
coming back to our diagram, what we're basically
proposing is that these type one
interferons, which are polarizing these
granulocytic or neutrophil cells that are already
recruited to the stomach,
that if we use an
inhibitor of cyclic GMP phosphodiesterases, such as
tadalafil or sildenafil,
that this will result in
preventing the breakdown of cyclic GMP
to keep this cycle going, regenerating the
substrate. And a buildup of cyclic GMP
will then be a cofactor for protein kinase G
and trigger these cells to undergo apoptosis.
And if these cells are destroyed and undergo
apoptosis, as I showed you earlier, even
deleting SLUFN4, you can trigger
apoptosis, then the thought is that you can
increase these effector T cells
because you no longer have this cell consuming L-arginine.
And I'll talk a little bit more or show a little bit more in terms of
mechanisms,
in terms of why these cells may undergo apoptosis
tomorrow on our poster.
So
I'm raising the question, can we disrupt the metabolism by
blocking the cyclic GMP
phosphodiesterases? Can we do this in a mouse model
first? And one of the problems with the
Helicobacter infection of mice, they don't
progress on to actual
cancer. So we actually took cues from
a colleague who had developed a human
secretion
model of IL-1 beta. Now, they
developed this by overexpressing essentially IL-1 beta in the
corpus of the mouse, but traditionally, Helicobacter
infection in people infects and
causes tumors in the distal part of the stomach in the
antrum. So essentially, we created a
gastrin Cre-ERT2, crossed it to
the Tet-on
activator,
and the Tet-operon was then
driving IL-1 beta. So this is a triple transgenic mouse that
was developed.
We used Cre to
activate... the
tet activator, and then the mice are put on
doxycycline. And then we alternate with a nitrate
carcinogen, MNU.
And then the
three cohorts of mice are also treated with sildenafil
to see whether we can shrink the tumors.
So what you see here are untreated mice,
mice in which IL1B is only overexpressed,
and then IL1B mice treated with sildenafil,
MNU alone, and then MNU plus
overexpressing IL1B, and then this mouse
treated with sildenafil. So you can see that about
45% of these mice
will develop tumors. So it's not a perfect
penetrance, but we do get nice, juicy tumors with
just this IL1B cytokine, and you can stain
for Schlafen4 to show that there is infiltration of the
Schlafen4 positive signal.
Those tumors tend to melt away with
sildenafil, and there's a decrease in the Schlafen4
positive cells. MNU, and I don't have
time to show the single-cell sequencing
that we've done. What's interesting is that this cytokine IL1B and
MNU, the nitrate, are different
pathways in terms of that get activated,
but both result in tumors, and an increase
in
the Schlafen signature. However, it's higher in
the IL1B mice. But the two together, you can see
synergize. We get really huge tumors, 90%
penetrance, yet sildenafil is still able to
decrease the size of those tumors.
So I took that data to our oncologist, and Junaid
Arshad is the lead oncologist
who takes care of the gastric cancer patients, and he presented his
poster earlier today. And so they said, "Well, we should try a window
trial," because I think most of us know you can do anything to mice
and see tumors shrink. But let's see what happens in people.
So again, we're looking at the Schlafen12L
signature.
Our protocol
is essentially... So I didn't know what a window trial was, but
it's an opportunity to actually use a treatment,
because these patients that we're recruiting are Stage 1 through
3. They will eventually go to surgery.
They will be getting neoadjuvant treatment.
At the time that we
opened the study, FLOT was the standard of care.
So Dr. Arshad said, "Well, let's try
tadalafil for two weeks, 20 milligrams a day," which is a little bit
higher than what we use for erectile dysfunction,
"and
then keep the patient on tadalafil, and then start
this four cycles of FLOT," and then they go to gastrectomy.
The
idea is that we would collect tissue, blood, and urine,
imaging before treatment, and
then do another endoscopy. So my
gastroenterology group,
we would do a second endoscopy here and collect
tissue after only tadalafil treatment to
do the single cell sequencing, and then just before
gastrectomy.
And then we would get tissue at the time of gastrectomy.
So this is just a quick summary.
Because patients drop out, one patient was metastatic, et cetera,
so roughly we're now up to 14 patients.
The last one needs to go to surgery.
I can come back if people have specific questions.
All the patients that we've tested were Helicobacter pylori at some point
in time. Two actually had active infection at the time of surgery.
Most were distal cancers. We had about 50/50 split
between males and females and a high Hispanic
population.
So
this is the spring plot for the single-cell
sequencing, and so what I want you to focus on will
be these two populations here in red.
And what we observe when we look at the
granulocytic MDSCs is that
you see here
in the pretreatment that the patients
with gastric cancer, so this is actually biopsying at the
time we're staging the patient. They usually come back for EUS, so we're able to
get additional biopsies and do the single cell sequencing,
and then biopsy the adjacent
to the tumor, that this is the group here
that are the Schlafen12L positive MDSCs,
but then after two weeks of tadalafil, there is a decrease
in this population. And then once we add the FLOT, you can
see that population is getting wiped out.
Yet, in the adjacent normal, whether you're
in the pretreatment phase or the other phases, those cells
aren't in the adjacent normal.
Okay. And then this is actually just showing the
Schlafen-positive signature. You'll see there are some other cells,
and one of the questions that we have that we haven't
had time to study is that this signature is also, or
Schlafen12L, is also being expressed by T cells.
We haven't pursued that in any detail, but the bulk of
the Schlafen-positive cells are this
granulocytic MDSC population, so you can see that
decreasing.And then
with treatment, the T cell population.
So
before treatment, the exhausted T cell population, as
well as the Tregs shown in purple,
are quite high, not
so impressive in the adjacent normal.
And then you can see with treatment that there is a decrease in the
exhausted T cell and Treg
population and an increase shown in red
of the CD8 positive cytotoxic T
cells.
To me, the exciting thing is that you can imagine that's a lot of work
to be able to
do single-cell sequencing at three intervals in the
tissue and the adjacent normal. So we
also
prepare
PBMCs and perform single-cell sequencing
on those patients at the same time.
And so pay attention to this cluster here, which are the
granulocytic MDSC signature. And again,
pretreatment, we see high levels of these granulocytic
MDSCs that with two weeks of tadalafil, there is a strong
decrease and then wiped out once we add the Flot.
I should say we didn't have enough patients, obviously, to do just a Flot
alone population.
And you see the increase in the cytotoxic T cells
as well as a decrease in the exhausted T cell
population.
So my summary slide is that
based upon our original question of
the role of hedgehog signaling in that transition
from chronic gastritis to
the metaplastic stage, since the mice don't go on to cancer,
we had to develop additional mouse models.
But it did give us clues that perhaps there was
a cell population that was worth following.
And so in summary, the inhibitors of
cyclic GMP phosphodiesterases, sildenafil and
tadalafil, and we chose those because
these granulocytic MDSCs seem to be dependent upon
these phosphodiesterases to
rev up their
reactive oxygen species and consume L-arginine.
And so if we block their ability to regenerate that
substrate with the sildenafil or tadalafil,
this will allow cyclic GMP to accumulate and trigger
those cells to undergo apoptosis.
As you know,
these drugs have been on the market since 2002, so
essentially they're off patent. They cost $33 to treat the
patients. It is minimal toxicity,
and so eventually it'll be interesting to see whether we can
combine this drug with other treatments.
I've shown you just tadalafil alone will affect
these granulocytic MDSCs and Tregs and
exhausted T cells by decreasing their population.
And what I think is exciting is that we can actually
follow this just with a blood draw now by following
them
in the PBMCs.
There are at least 11, I said
cyclic two, but there's 11 phosphodiesterases.
The ones that are cyclic GMP dependent
exclusively are 11, five, and six.
What's interesting is that in these granulocytic
MDSCs, based upon our single cell sequencing as well as the bulk
RNA-seq,
these cells actually are expressing PDE6, not
five. So that may be an opportunity to develop more specific
drugs that will hit only six and not five.
It's certainly a viable option as a neoadjuvant with standard of care
chemotherapy. And so our next step is to expand this
study to include an immune checkpoint inhibitor with
Flot.
So with that,
I'll take any questions. I'd just like to acknowledge Lin Ding
who has worked on this project really for the last
10 years and really has taken it from a lot of the mouse
mechanistic studies to
assisting with the single cell sequencing.
I'd like to acknowledge my division of
gastroenterology, and my advanced
endoscopists that are willing to take those extra
biopsies,
our division of Hemonc and specifically Junaid
Arshad, who
sees and refers these patients,
the patient participants, donors to our
biorepository, and our clinical
coordinator.
And with that, I'll take any questions, and thank you for your
attention.
Thank you for the talk. Great talk.
So I have a question about the
immunosuppressive mechanism of MDSC.
So you mentioned arginase one,
which is indeed demonstrated in mice, but as you might know,
it's not that clear in humans. And it is debated
whether arginase one is really involved in suppression by human MDSC.
So did you look at arginase one expression in your human analysis
of granulocytic MDSCs?
So you're saying that arginase-1
is not expressed in
human? Is that what you're saying?
Yeah. That's what people say, yes.
So what's interesting, at least with the single-cell sequencing, we can see the
arginase-1 signature. Now, we can't see the nitric oxide-2.
That one, my understanding, is what's difficult to pick up.
But you do see arginase-1?
Yeah. In the single-cell sequencing.
Okay.
Go ahead.
So my question is, how early in the
development of gastric cancer do you see
the
neutrophilic effects,
and presumably MDS2s?
There's
several different ways of reducing that I've
heard just in the last two or three days.
One of them is associated with vaccines, which was presented today,
the fairly dramatic change in pancreatic cancer vaccines
in reducing the number of type II macrophage and monocyte.
Another was
a molecule called Chili or Chill
that apparently dramatically reduces immune suppression.
In that case, the immune suppression
is associated with neutrophilic
infiltrates, the formation of netopathies,
and type II
macrophage. So the question is, how
early in the transition from a pre-malignant to a malignant
state, particularly in gastric cancer,
does the effect of
phosphodiesterase inhibitors
possibly play a role? And do you want to treat very early as opposed to
later?
So all of the patients that were recruited are stage
I or stage II. Most of them are distal.
We do have some cardiac cancers. I think there were three or four that were
cardiac cancers.
And all of them get the tadalafil for two weeks, and we're
seeing a decrease at least by two weeks.
It's not completely gone.
So you are getting a response within two weeks at 20 milligrams,
which is higher than what
is used for pulmonary hypertension or erectile dysfunction.
I guess what I was asking was, can you use this earlier than even
stage I during
preventing the transition from metaplasia to-
Okay. So you're asking about using it as a preventive
mechanism. I would say
there really isn't
any drug, even aspirin, which we use to
suppress colon polyps, but even that's going to cause
some side effects with GI bleeding.
And so it's generally not recommended to use it
for preventative measures, and I think it's going to
be hard to get through the US Preventative Task Force.
I just don't think we're going to have enough patients to do it.
I'm not saying necessarily it would be a bad idea.
I just don't know that it'll get approved.
I am working with a group at Case Western that has looked
at
the TriNetX
database, and they have found that there is about a
30% reduction in
both colon and gastric cancer,
in patients that
were on any of the three
cyclic GMP phosphodiesterases. I'm pushing them to get that
out in the literature because it's
been rumored, it's been out there that these drugs
are anti-neoplastic. It's just that nobody really-
Yeah. I'm proposing a very specific mechanism that you can look at
based on, in this case, it's neutrophils or platelets.
Mm-hmm.
There was a proposal for one of those drugs
with a change in the human immune system.
Something very specific as mechanism.
Right. So again, we're taking it further and trying to look at the mechanism.
The epidemiology will be helpful to basically show on a
population-wide basis that these drugs probably have some
effect. They may not have an effect, obviously.
We were focused on the GI cancers. They didn't look at
pancreatic.
But there are some clinical trials where they've
looked at head and neck cancer and I think melanoma.
Thank you.
Uh-huh.
Okay.
You have
principal
component analysis for the cell populations.
Did you have any spatial data?
No. We have slides.
Yeah.
But we need somebody to do that
for us.
Yeah, because I'm looking at VRAO to see if you can sit there.
Yeah.
And you don't know where they are.
Yeah, I agree.
Wow.
It was fun. Sorry.
Oh, where are you-
Going? No, I was going around.
Where are you?
Aragon. Oh, yeah, you said.
I'm sorry. Just-
It's okay.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, it's nice.
Yeah, it's pretty. Originally from California.
Oh.
I've always wanted to go to the desert.
Oh, yeah.
Is it still there?
Yeah.
We hope so.
So how-
Well, they're hopeful by alone.
Right.
Yeah.
So the mouse model, and yeah, in a mouse, but I think it's
my understanding once you get to humans, it
should-
These are mice.
Yeah, these are mice. And I think,
so yeah, this is the JX9. I think, is this the melanoma
one? So this group first looked at it in melanoma, and
then they did a mouse model.
Okay.
But you may want to go back further
to where was it the first...
And actually, that's where I first got the idea, because of the
hedgehog signal.
I was at a hedgehog meeting, and there was a clinical oncologist
that said, "Oh, yeah, we used
Gositumumab in
2000, and we just gave up on it because there was no money."
And they said the problem is
no
one makes the drug anymore. Even if you go
on it, I know exactly how, I know the binding, but what do they do?
So that's why the point is that working out,
being able to isolate even just the subpopulation and
really understanding what it does,
because it's really garbage. You see why nobody
tried this in any population because it doesn't pass.
It really was repurposed by the drug
companies. Mine was Ben
Honzingers, but that's why we wanted to-- We probably have to go to Europe
to publish it because we're going to get blocked out of the
American
literature.
So
the biggest group that's taking this drug,
and obviously in men, is 5 milligrams a day
for erectile dysfunction. So that's a lot of what that
TriNet database that-- So it's a US
database of, I think, ICD
codes or something like that.
So they don't have a lot of granular information.
They can just say, okay, these patients came in
with this code, and they're on these drugs,
and how long did they live if they had cancer.
And they have a control group. So I'm trying to get them to publish that
because our co-author is at Ivy Tech here in New
Orleans. But yeah, our next step is we get to
combine it with the checkpoint inhibitors.
Yeah. Yeah, but yeah.
Interesting. Okay, thank you.